welcome back to las vegas now even
though it's the afternoon we are saying
good morning because that's the name of
this delicious french restaurant that we
are talking about today and thank you
cisco for sponsoring today's segment and
joining us from good morning is danielle
carell and patty orozco yes yes we got
it
thank you guys so much for being here
this looks amazing but it smells amazing
and i have to say i am pretty much in
walking distance from your restaurant
and i drive by it all the time and i've
never been in so when i finally make my
way in tell me what's on the menu and
give me some suggestions of what to
order for sure you got it so today we
brought uh some of our most popular
dishes with like the pancake board if
you're like a pancake lover yeah
marshmallows we have the chocolate
abuelita the syrup uh we have a bourbon
syrup made in-house wow it's it's really
good you sure to try now chicken and
waffles the classic love it you can't go
wrong this reminds me of like a
charcuterie board but for brunch so i'm
all about it and
we actually have one we have one oh my
gosh okay so we can do a little bit of
everything sweet and savory of course
and i had no idea that you guys have
cocktails so let's talk is that a flight
that i see up there yes that's our
mimosa flight we have four different
flavors per flight oh my gosh today we
have orange
we have some pineapple strawberry and
hibiscus wow do you have a favorite out
of those are they
they're all gritty
okay i like to consider myself like a
mimosa connoisseur so i'm definitely
coming in to try that and let's talk
about some of the other beautiful
cocktails yeah so here we have the uh
napoli spritz it's made with a homemade
limoncello wow and sparkling wine
cucumber vodka as well then we got our
flowers in the attic it's our uh it's a
botanical gin with a butterfly pea
blossom flour oh my gosh that's so
refreshing yes and then we got the
vitamin scala of meat which is made with
morita chile
infuse mezcal with beet juice as well
and
some homemade beet salt as well wow this
all looks delicious i want a little bit
of everything and let's just talk about
the feel of the restaurant i was looking
at some of the photos online it's
beautiful in there what do you want
people to experience when they come
through the doors it's it's not just
about the food that we have
it's the experience you get the service
the aesthetics of the place it's just
beautiful and you should you should try
it i can explain all i want but you
should go and see for yourself and go
enjoy for myself okay well i'm
definitely going to maybe i'll walk
there so i can have a bunch of emotions
and then just go home
all right we'll tell people the location
and where and when you're open all that
fun stuff we are located in 5587 rainbow
boulevard uh we open at 9 00 a.m we
close at 3 p.m okay so you can come in
all day all right
pick your favorite drink for me and i'll
take a little sip at the end of our
segment
this is a favorite for all of us maybe
that's the one i was hoping you would
pick so i'm really excited here i'll
take the same chairs over here it's pink
it's beautiful you guys this is so much
fun you have definitely convinced me to
come in so go check out good morning
cheers to you guys we have all the
information on your screen here there's
the address you can call them make
reservations website and mention that
you saw us here on klas 8 and received
10 off thank you again to our sponsor
cisco for this cheers you guys thank you
so much thank you and disney's thing two
is